utiliza la herramienta de traslación
para determinar la traslación que mapear
al triángulo w n
este es el triángulo doble n en el otro
triángulo entonces veamos si podemos
hacer esta traslación vamos a utilizar
esta herramienta de traslación
si yo aquí agregó una traslación
entonces dice traslación por aquí vamos
a indicar cuántas unidades nos vamos a
trasladar en la coordenada x y aquí
vamos a indicar cuántas unidades nos
vamos a trasladar en la coordenada y así
que veamos si yo quiero mapear al punto
w en este punto porque bueno parece ser
que el punto w corresponde a este punto
tendría que moverme de x2 a x igual a
menos 5 entonces mi coordenada x deberá
de crecer 7 unidades así que aquí voy a
poner traslación x
x menos 7 vemos que solo componer menos
7 la imagen del triángulo w n se mueve 7
unidades a la izquierda y ahora para el
eje de las yes necesito bajarlo veamos
cuántas unidades serían 1 2 3 4 unidades
entonces en el eje de las yes va a
decrecer cuatro unidades pongo aquí
menos cuatro y tal parece ser que si
tuvimos éxito cierto pudimos trasladar
al triángulo w n en este triángulo que
se nos indicó y lo hicimos trasladando
la coordenada x siete unidades a la
izquierda entonces todos los puntos de
este triángulo del triángulo w n se
trasladaron siete unidades a la
izquierda y en el eje de las yes todos
los puntos del triángulo w en from
traslada 24 unidades hacia abajo y así
pudimos hacer la traslación para que
este triángulo para que el triángulo w n
de mapear a en este triángulo que se nos
indicó entonces comprobamos
correcto